hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's V are help-wanted there are
only night terrors left in the main
portion of the game I'm not talking
about the butthole dimension that is
this version of the game no that's
something completely different I don't
even know what this is about and I don't
think I want to know what this is about
so I'm not gonna pretend like I know
what this is about
and I'm gonna be I'm just gonna we're
just gonna move on out of there and
pretend like that's not actually a thing
because it doesn't have to be a thing
until it's actually a thing but for
right now we're gonna go into night
terrors and that looks like five nights
at Freddy's 4 but it's not saying it's
five nights at Freddy's 4 which leads me
to believe that it's something different
I don't know what exactly but I know I'm
gonna hate it oh I hate it I hate it
already closed doors and grab and
release with trigger ah nope flashlight
person hold stick no teleport point and
pull trigger that I I feel like I'll
miss set up survived oh if you say so
that sounds totally fair let's whatever
let's just go and die oh hey what the
hell whoa oh oh oh oh
am i listening oh god am i listening hi
hello hi
do i this is the worst oh oh hi hello
how are you good to see you I don't know
what I'm doing I don't know how I'm
doing it I don't know what they expect
me to do oh okay is that is that all
what do I do
I don't want to go to the doors I want
to go to the middle how do we go to the
middle Oh God okay oh hi uh no thanks
just no thanks whoa
what the hell you still there you still
there you still you still there okay
you're still there I'm gonna dr. to hand
this
I don't what do I do about you there's
no way to go back hi okay yeah okay sure
there's no way to go back it's
impossible to go back once I've gone
forward I can never go back I'll just
stare at you for a long time body you
are a fun friend
fun times with friends friendly fun
times I don't even think I can leave can
I it's it's not letting me move anywhere
I'm stuck here so it's just you and me
for a little bit so all I can do with my
time here is judge you I think your
color combination is deplorable
which means bad in case your brain was
too small to understand what deplorable
man with nothing by that blank deer-like
expression on your face is accurate so
you're stupid and I'm smart if you want
to ask [ __ ] goodbye you I'm not done
with you I'll judge you whoever you were
later I'm judging you right now so
listen to me and listen good
oh you're stunning there you can't
believe I'm revealing the truth of your
own existing to your own face you suck
your little pink mustache it's just a
ripoff of Worf - yeah I know you're just
a fanboy or whatever you are I know
you're just a fan and that's all you'll
ever be just a fan funtime fanboy Freddy
so I hope you take this as a lesson
learned that you suck and I'm awesome so
don't even think don't even think about
coming back here ever ever ever again
ever never never all right good glad we
got that cleared up thank you what time
is yeah yeah that's what I thought yeah
I beat that right yeah I beat this game
good there's no timer what hardly I'm in
the void oh you did well you could
always try again sucker oh I don't need
to be a sucker to beat you up
buuck a point wait my punches yeah
right [ __ ] they do nothing they do
nothing that's what I said but that's
what I said I'm in your mind oh god I
think you're in my mind can you know me
the fair fair
I played Oh God uh night marry own wait
marry own is that the name all right
name irione I don't know I still don't
know how to beat this I beat the other
one just by a fluke so um that's open
now it's ain't good
I know that for certainty right who what
what well I do worry about that do I go
in how do I go in what do I do whoa whoa
whoa
whoo oh [ __ ] whoa my god oh my god
what is that [ __ ] my sister what oh oh
oh oh oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god what am i doing what am i doing
oh my god I didn't create anything come
on okay I can't see I'm closing it Oh
oh my god oh why is it so tentacle like
oh I can't see down there I don't know
what that is all about I've got the
foggiest what that's all about and I
don't know what what-do-i-do
what-do-i-do what-do-i-do what-do-i-do
what-do-i-do what-do-i-do well I'm just
asking as clear as I can ask what do i
do what do i do I don't know what I do I
don't know why any of this I can't go I
can't get the closet oh I don't know
what
I'm gonna bite the big one here about to
bite some big ones big ones are about to
be bit you know I'm just gonna leave
okay so there whatever it is flashlights
weird arcing whatever it is [ __ ] is that
noise okay you're not there but I hear
the goofiness loopiness [ __ ] [ __ ] this
one doesn't make a lot of sense to me
but I'll figure it out I will figure
this out what do I do
I don't wait whoa whoa whoa whoa [ __ ]
the ice okay the ice got it
understood duly noted okay so I got to
make him go all the way away and then
what do I go over there now uh don't see
nothing there all the way away okay okay
all right so the eyes the eyes are the
thing look for the eyes there's some ice
close the door and look at the tentacles
that seems like a logical thing to
definitely do in my spare time in my
experience best thing I've ever done is
look at tentacles and eyes always good
moves in my book
yeah you are oh my god all the way away
all the way all the way way over there
what about over here in the eyes no go
away go away go away go away
you suck just go away all the way away
okay you still there I bet I bet I bet I
bet uh Ben yeah yeah okay
this doesn't make the most sense in the
world but but I'm fine with it
no no no no no go away go away you over
there you're a parent no you're not over
here okay Rory go away go away go away
away away away away away away away wait
layaway layaway [ __ ] I was very close I
was close it was 5:00 a.m. I just
they're going over yep yep yep yep yep
yep first peppers peppers peppers
peppers Pitino's oh yeah purse peppers
okay
Wow don't scare me before I don't get
good huh Frick frack Rock good that was
just panicking so Neroni innovation in
carbonation Wow I don't know why the
whole can the crunch was not reassuring
okay here we go
circus baby you're not gonna be me now
that I know generally the recipe they're
gonna change the recipe aren't they
Oh grab release Oh close the doors
that's all I got to do
oh well then so this will be easy all I
gotta do is close the doors whoa it's
not your birthday did I leave the doors
closed forever remember Jeremy do
remember Jeremy thank you I got a tape
to remember Jeremy but that doesn't mean
that I have to remember Jeremy I don't
know who Jeremy is and I don't care who
Jeremy is to be frank you can always
tell when a company is getting ready to
fire someone they start giving out
written warnings for silly things making
sure to build a paper trail and make a
case for a fiery things that normally no
one would care about suddenly become
grave offenses all worthy of being
written and documented I guess it works
two ways because it also encourages a
person to quit rather than be
scrutinized so
I think Jeremy was too far gone to
consider that option though the thing
about it is but I don't think they were
going to fire him because of anything he
was doing wrong right
they just knew he'd seen something they
needed to discredit him right okay
Jeremy sure I don't know Jeremy is but
he obviously has done bad if he went
against the company's wishes hi there
how are you doing good good great good
great good great I'm gonna go back in
here um so maybe I panicked I think what
it was is that close the doors for too
long the shaky babies didn't like that
and if they get too shaky there no happy
I get it I get it I understand I'm the
same way okay ah then what am i okay so
maybe I just got a letter see me so that
I go
that's weird hi you don't need to know I
thought you would have been gone I
thought I really thought I thought I
thought okay all right okay so this
ain't so bad I think what I gotta do is
I just got time to close cuz no matter
what I think she's gonna see me unless
she doesn't wake me unless she
unless she doesn't unless I can time it
so that she doesn't see me - oh no she
sees me no matter what oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
okay can you see me okay well no what
are you what are you thinking oh don't
do that okay you don't have good object
permanence oh [ __ ] okay all right I can
deal with this I can deal with this
hey yes I happen to be in the same
closet that you lost me last time
all right whoo
want to see the scooping well no I don't
not really
[Music]
I'm here hello
peekaboo this is a big game of peekaboo
with the baby that's what it is it's
peekaboo with the baby it'd be goo you
guys like playing peekaboo I like name I
guess you forgot about me huh you big
dumb loser I'm over here it literally is
a game of peekaboo with a giant baby
that's what this game mode is that's
hilarious
I guess no I didn't did you forget about
me why do you have pins in your body you
do an acupuncture did I win
what the [ __ ] Oh goodbye single-serving
butterstick
I mean they're common but they're still
appreciated in these trying times a a
sweet succulent well not sweet a buttery
succulent butter for one to die for
divine direct would you like to hear a
funny fun fact
sure would the previous development
teams made a hilarious mistake and that
may or may not have resulted in an
undesirable anomaly entering the game's
code
please accept that statement as our full
legal disclaimer and absolution of
responsibility and potential harm to you
that is fine that is a really funny fact
that is for all nighttime fredbear okay
that don't see me okay but if it's the
same format that I'm thinking it'll be
okay okay
doors teleport got it okay so it should
just be a matter of
this oh god I can go to the closet now
okay fine fine by me are you listen what
sup hey you here
alright am I gonna be looking for teeth
or something whoa oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
okay like there's something over there
just something here okay so what is this
about what do I do
wait oh [ __ ] hi umm okay you're there
so I hear him I hear him tramps around
I'm sure that means something
okay so he's not there I hear where's he
going
going over here no oh wow wow oh wait
wait wait wait whoa what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] wait doing it does that mean I
need to close the closet what the [ __ ]
does that mean
wait wait what the [ __ ] does that mean
does that mean I remember this in five
nights at freddys far but I don't
remember what the things mean when they
happen hello coming down this way oh
[ __ ] Ida [ __ ] [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god oh my chicken here
here I look away from one goddamn second
[Music]
I swear I look away one goddamn second
that sounds like the other one no oh
yeah every time every frickin time
I check this cloth because I don't know
what the [ __ ] is up with this or why
Oh Josie oh [ __ ] so sauce here wait left
he's gonna
oh my god
oh my god why did I need the closet why
did I need the closet why did I need to
closet why probably for the nightmare
mode oh I'm sorry that was an accident
I'm saying you're still clumsy that's
why my big sister doesn't like you
well I don't like your big sister much
either Wow how dare you I'll pick your
idea weak weak oh my eyes all right cool
I'm gonna go with my tape I'm sure it'll
be fine oh hi wow I can see you in kind
of detail now that ain't good
are you Jeremy there was something that
looked like a Halloween mask
laying on the floor I didn't understand
Inc must have spilled it was only then
that I heard a shuffle from the testing
room and realized Jeremy must be there I
went back and peered in the window I
couldn't see his face
he had the visor covering his head he
had ink spilled on himself as well the
front of his shirt looked black in the
dark run he turned his head in my
direction but I don't think he knew I
was there I'm thinking that wasn't ink
I'm thinking you know I'm just
respecting that might not have been ink
I'm thinking that might have been blood
would you you know what I mean it might
have been blued it might have been big
ol beefy blued okay so that is the last
of the normal game modes that is it
that's all of them so what happens now
is this [ __ ] there's only one of those
Oh No
[Music]
don't tell me they combined all of the
characters at once cuz that's awful oh
no no no okay all right well that sucks
but yeah so that's what we have to look
forward to but you know what I don't
have to look forward to it that's a
problem for future me that's a problem
for the me that's not here right now
that's a future me problem and you know
what's beautiful is that you can just
push your problems off into the future
indefinitely because future you will
always be there until you die and then
when you die you don't have to worry
about the problems anymore see it's just
logical sense so thank you everybody so
much for watching I'll have more fun
Daisy Freddy's coming at you real soon
real hot and heavy but in the meantime
thank you everybody so much for watching
I don't know how long it'll take me to
beat these maybe they're not like 2020
mode hard we're gonna find out so
probably tomorrow there'll be another
episode of this and we'll see what
happens so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]